[Música]
en revista de prensa hoy comenzaremos un
debate que hay en Estados Unidos luego
de la muerte de tyry Nichols este
afroamericano que murió a manos de cinco
policías de la ciudad de Memphis Rosa
Pérez Buenos días Buenos días media
Clara bueno y Comencemos con un artículo
del Washington post sobre todo porque
ahora el debate es la el racismo
sistémico en la policía del país Porque
estos cinco policías también eran
también son afroamericanos efectivamente
Y este artículo por el que empezamos del
Washington se titula los policías negros
de Memphis desencadenan el debate sobre
el racismo sistémico en Estados Unidos
precisamente y el artículo empieza con
una cita de Rogue van Wells la madre
precisamente del fallecido tairine
Nichols que dice el hecho de que los
cinco agentes de policía acusados de
aparilizar a mi hijo también sean negros
ha grabado mi dolor mientras intento
asimilar la violenta muerte de mi hijo
de 29 años todavía lo hace más difícil
de tragar porque son negros y saben lo
que tenemos que pasar este artículo del
washings señala las dos ramas no en las
que se ha diversificado este debate por
un lado señala que los medios de extrema
derecha han usado el caso para señalar
que no existe tal racismo sistémico
mientras que activistas anti racistas y
la mayoría de medios de comunicación
como vamos a ver a continuación señalan
que precisamente el hecho de que se
hable de una cuestión sistémica Lo que
implica es que se pueda manifestar en
acciones de personas en este caso no
blancas porque estamos hablando de
racismo En todo caso es que nadie está
exento de una cuestión que estructura y
que vértebra la sociedad como sería en
este caso el racismo precisamente señala
este artículo del Washington post que en
a Memphis se han hecho esfuerzos en los
últimos años para que el cuerpo de
policía digamos fuera representativo del
porcentaje de afro estadounidenses en la
ciudad y es que un 58% del cuerpo de
policía es afro estadounidense mientras
que un cuatro por ciento de la ciudad
también lo es pero que sin embargo
señalara este artículo esto no libera no
las acciones del cuerpo policial de la
ciudad de que también tengan componentes
componentes Perdón racistas la jefa de
policía de Memphis Eso sí actuó con más
rapidez que en otras circunstancias y
esto me voy a aclarar también es un
punto central del debate Y es que hay
que enseñarla que se ha actuado
precisamente con más celeridad contra
estos cinco policías negros que con
otros policías blancos y para terminar
con este artículo se cita también a
Chanel Austin quien dirige el Memorial
de George Floyd que teme que la
judialización del caso de estos cinco
policías al final refuerza el discurso
de las Manzanas podridas y
eclipse el hecho de que se trata de una
cuestión estructural del cuerpo de
policía y como usted lo adelantó Vamos a
repasar varios medios de comunicación el
usa today habla de la raza dentro de la
policía no es así exactamente y
básicamente nos centramos en un artículo
que dice expertos activistas y abogados
señalan que la de los agentes
involucrados es mucho menos importante
que la de la víctima una cultura
policial históricamente sesgada pone en
riesgo a las personas negras
independientemente de la raza de los
agentes no y señalan una cita de Rusia
Robinson presidente de la asociación
color of change que dice tenemos un
problema profundo que va más allá del
blanco y el negro se trata del azul y
que dice el New York Times el New York
Times señala que precisamente no los
problemas de raza y vigilancia son el
resultado de una cultura policial
arraigada en la agresión y la
deshumanización de las personas negras
más que del racismo interpersonal no de
nuevo esta misma tesis el entrenamiento
las prácticas y tácticas policiales la
cultura del cuerpo policial son más
fuertes que el color de piel de la gente
y también señala esto no de que los
agentes de hecho estos cinco agentes
Implicados En este caso que como
decíamos están acusados Ya de asesinato
en segundo grado también serán digamos
juzgados con ciertos sesgos racistas y
el Boston Cloud
digamos es un artículo de los más
profundos que hemos encontrado en
relación a este caso y dice las
propuestas de reformas policiales a
nivel Federal no habrían salvado la vida
de tarin y calles ni siquiera esta ley
de seguridad llamada George Floyd que
está bloqueada a nivel federal y que
quiere prohibir ciertas tácticas
policiales como serían el
estrangulamiento dice este artículo en
Nichols solo estaría vivos y Estados
Unidos hubiera adoptado una perspectiva
abolicionista sobre el castigo la
prisión y la vigilancia dice la
abolicionismo moderno este movimiento
tiene raíces en la lucha por La
abolición de la esclavitud sin embargo
años décadas después sigue habiendo una
desconexión deliberada entre las ideas
abolicionistas las políticas públicas y
la comprensión de la sociedad
estadounidense de la relación entre
vigilancia Crimen y Castigo pobreza
segregación racial concepciones
nacionales de dignidad y ciudadanía dice
que la transformación que necesita la
sociedad como decíamos va más allá de la
prohibición de estrangulamientos no dice
que el asesinato policial de tyran y
calles está vi a una larga historia de
instituciones estadounidenses que
criminalizan los cuerpos negros el más
allá de la esclavitud dice se continúa
viendo en la segregación escolar en La
Brecha económica en la segregación
Residencial pero sobre todo en el valor
barato de la vida negra a manos de la
autoridad institucional y le propongo
que terminemos con la portada deliberase
Exacto la portada de este medio francés
también va dedicada a este caso de
brutalidad policial de racismo sistémico
y se titula Estados Unidos está enfermo
de su policía lo vemos aquí con esta
imagen y el siguiente texto el
linchamiento de tarrítmicos por cinco
policías también negros arroja luz sobre
el racismo sistémico en Estados Unidos y
la violencia persistente en las fuerzas
del orden 10 años después de la
emergencia de Black lives matter Rosa
gracias por este gran repaso sobre la
prensa internacional a ti María Clara